[Music]
hey everyone welcome to our installments
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing Severus
Snape Lord Voldemort and why Snape
didn't strike Voldemort down when he was
in a weakest state preventing him from
maintaining a physical form Snape is a
double agent which means that for the
duration of the books and films
Snape's loyalties were still very much
unclear to many both sides thought they
had an ally but we later find out that
despite his dubious past Snape is good
all along what this means is that he
would have had many opportunities to
attack Voldemort when he was in one of
his more primitive forms he was in the
inner circle of Death Eaters an access
to Voldemort would have been at his
fingertips Snape is one of the most
powerful wizards in the entire Wizarding
World and striking down a weakened
Voldemort would have been no issue for
him so why not do it why allow Voldemort
to achieve his full levels of power sure
attacking Voldemort wouldn't completely
kill him because of his Horcruxes
but if Snape had used two varta Kedavra
and Voldemort and he would have at least
stripped him of his physical form making
him easier to deal with the time that
Voldemort was in a non corporeal form
could have been used to hunt down and
destroy the rest of the Horcruxes
first of all Voldemort had been brought
back to a physical form once and it
could be easily replicated again
particularly because after achieving his
physical form
Voldemort gave a long spiel in the
graveyard to his death eaters but how it
was done the first time he lost his
corporeal form things were a bit more
dire and that's why it took so long I
remember only forcing myself sleeplessly
endlessly second-by-second to exist I
settled in a faraway place in a forest
and I waited surely one of my faithful
Death Eaters would try and find me one
of them and come and perform the magic I
could not to restore me to a body but I
waited in vain however thanks to
Wormtail and Voldemort's knowledge of a
potion that would be able to help him
achieve a corporeal form once again he
was able to accomplish his goal but I
was willing to embrace mortal life again
before chasing immortal I set my sights
lower I would settle for my old body
back again and my old strength I knew
that to achieve this it is an old piece
of dark magic
the potion that revived me tonight I
would need three powerful ingredients
well one of them was already at hand
was it not worm tell flesh given by a
servant my father's bone naturally meant
that we would have to come here where he
was buried but the blood of a faux worm
tail would have had me use any wizard
would do not worm tell any wizard who
had hated me as so many of them still do
but I knew the one I must use if I was
to rise again more powerful than I had
been when I had fallen I wanted Harry
Potter's blood I wanted the blood of the
one who had stripped me of power
thirteen years ago for the lingering
protection his mother once gave him
would then reside in my veins too
because the Death Eaters now knew how
easy it was for Voldemort once again
assumed a physical form it's unlikely
dude's name would act impulsively and
kill Voldemort because what would he did
chief the first time took many many
years but if he could now return to his
physical form in a week but it'd really
be worth it for Snape to blow his cover
killing him would also be a dangerous
mission it could potentially cost him
his life if something went awry an
assassination attempt is no easy task
particularly on the Dark Lord Himself
who surrounds himself with keen
protective and loyal Death Eaters it
would be risky even for Snape and there
is always the chance that Voldemort
could have seen the attack coming
Voldemort is a master at legitimacy
which is the art of magically navigating
the mind of another extracting their
feelings and memories yes Snape is a
master Aquaman's which means that he is
able to close off his mind to legitimacy
and very effectively at that but killing
someone particularly with the killing
curse requires an abundance of emotion
and it's hard to imagine that a master
legitimates like Voldemort wouldn't
detect it Snape was able to trick the
Death Eaters
for years but he always tread carefully
stepping out of line and plotting to
kill Voldemort with an unforgivable
curse is another story altogether the
following excerpts from the text
described the emotion required to cast
the killing curse Avada Kedavra is a
cursed that needs a powerful bit of
magic behind it you could all get your
ones up now and point them at me and say
the words and I doubt it get so much as
a nosebleed but that doesn't matter I'm
not here to teach you how to do it also
never use an unforgivable curse before
have you boy she yelled she had
abandoned her baby voice now
you need to mean them Potter you need to
really want to cause pain to enjoy it
righteous anger won't hurt me for long
I'll show you how it's done
shall I so my theory is that mustering
up the necessary emotions required to
cast the killing curse would be noticed
by Voldemort making the mission
unbelievably dangerous if Snape and
Dumbledore had felt that this was
plausible then I'm sure they would have
gone ahead with it sooner the final
reason that Snape didn't kill Voldemort
is that his final Horcrux the Horcrux
inside of Harry needed to be destroyed
by Voldemort himself tell him that on
the night Lord Voldemort tried to kill
him when Lily cast her own life between
them as a shield the killing curse
rebounded upon Lord Voldemort when a
fragment of Voldemort soul was blasted
apart from the whole and latched itself
onto the only living soul left in that
collapsing building part of Lord
Voldemort lives inside Harry and his
that which gives him the power of speech
with snakes and the connection with Lord
Voldemort's mind that he has never
understood and while that fragment of
soul UNMISS told Mort remains attached
to and protected by Harry
Lord Voldemort cannot die Harry seemed
to be watching the two men from one end
of the long tunnel they were so far away
from him the voices echoing strangely in
his ears so the boy the boy must die
asked Snape quite calmly and Voldemort
himself must do it Severus that is
essential for Voldemort to be properly
destroyed it was essential that
Voldemort himself be the one to destroy
his final Horcrux which meant that it
was imperative that he maintains a
physical form of some kind
if Snape had killed Voldemort
prematurely it would have only delayed
the inevitable
additionally despite being on the inner
circle of both sides of the battle Snape
is so very much unaware of a lot of the
things happening behind the scenes he
doesn't know about the relationship
between Harry and the Horcruxes and this
is because Dumbledore had been very
vague when discussing plans with him all
he knows is that Dumbledore made it
abundantly clear that Voldemort would
have to be the one to kill Harry so to
conclude Snape didn't kill Voldemort
because it just didn't make sense it
would have bought time but how much a
week he would have risked his life cut
ties with the Death Eaters and Voldemort
would have been back again in a couple
form in no time at all additionally with
Voldemort's corporeal form gone the
Horcrux in Harry would have lived on
only further perpetuating Voldemort's
existence and that's it for this video I
hope you enjoyed it what do you think
would have happened if Snape killed
Voldemort earlier on let us know down in
the comments section below until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]